Our immune system protects us from the
outside world. But how do our bodies
know what belongs and what does not
belong? One of the tools our immune
system uses to protect us is called the
antibody. These Y-shaped proteins can
attach to things that don't belong,
intruders like viruses or bacteria.
What's cool is that our bodies can make
billions of types of antibodies, which
protect us from lots of different
things. Antibodies have two parts. The
stem is called a constant region, and
the two arms are called the variable
region. While the constant region of
the antibodies look the same, the
variable region can have different
shapes.
This allows the arms to connect, or to
bind, to intruders in the body, based
on how the intruders are shaped. Here,
we'll introduce an important concept in
antibodies: specificity. Specificity
tells us how well the binding site
shape of an antibody fits the intruder
it wants to catch, a.k.a., how well the
puzzle pieces fit together. But where
are antibodies? Antibodies are always
moving around our body, riding along in
our blood. When they come across an
intruder they are specific for, they
can bind to it. Antibodies can protect
us in two main ways. One, multiple
antibodies can connect or bind to
multiple molecules at once and stick
together to stop the intruder. Or two,
once an antibody binds to an intruder,
it's constant region sticks out and is
available to bind to specific immune
cells. When enough antibodies connect
to the thing that doesn't belong, our
immune cells recognize the antibodies
and eat the intruder.
But sometimes our immune system doesn't
always get it right. Usually, we don't
have to worry about our antibodies
attacking us because we create
antibodies that are specific only to
bad things, like intruders. However,
some people have diseases where their
antibodies can't tell the difference
between what does and does not belong.
We can call these diseases autoimmune
diseases because the body is attacking
itself. By better understanding how the
immune system and antibodies work, we
have been able to help people with
these diseases, but there is still much
to be discovered.